une ville fantôme malgré la fin du
confinement et des mesures sanitaires
les rues de Pékin ont rarement été
autant déserte quatre jours après la fin
de la politique officielle de covid 0 le
nombre de contaminations a explosé déjà
10% de la population est infectée selon
plusieurs estimations les autres restent
chez eux de peur de l'attraper les seuls
attroupements dans la capitale sont
devant les pharmacies ou les gens font
la queue pour se procurer des autotests
de dépistage seul moyen de connaître son
état depuis la fin des tests PCR
obligatoire cette dame dit à avoir été
dans plusieurs pharmacies pour se
trouver un test antigène mais sans
succès
cet homme lui se désespère d'en trouver
et s'inquiète en raison de son mal de
gorge terminé aussi l'application
anticovid qui permettait de suivre les
déplacements et d'avertir en cas
d'exposition officiellement le nombre de
nouvelles infections est en baisse mais
dans ce contexte où l'on ne teste plus
les chiffres officiels ne veulent plus
rien dire on va très vite voir s'il y a
une association avec un taux
d'hospitalisation qui monte en flèche
comme montre le nombre de cas je pense
que c'est ça qui va nous donner une
petite idée de comment ça va se traduire
dans la population selon une étude de la
revue scientifique Nature médecine la
levée soudaine des restrictions risque
de causer plus d'un million et demi de
morts et d'envoyer près de 6 millions de
personnes aux soins intensifs en cause
le faible taux de vaccination des
personnes âgées moins des deux tiers des
Chinois de plus de 80 ans ont été
vaccinées deux fois 20% seulement ont
reçu une troisième dose ça serait d'être
vraiment très optimiste de dire que la
Chine peut sortir de manière aussi
drastique de ces mesures sanitaires
extrêmement sévères sans faire face à
une vague d'hospitalisation
sévère peu importe pour le moment la fin
de la politique covid 0 est bien reçue
ça ne sert à rien de s'inquiéter de ce
Resident Pékin il suffit de se protéger
à one ou l'épidémie a débuté le
déconfinement est vécu comme une
libération
que ça dure 17 jeunes femmes de 24 ans
pour suivre le confinement nous aurons
obligés à passer toute notre jeunesse à
la maison
mais le retour à la vie normale en Chine
n'est pas pour demain surtout qu'avec la
fin des restrictions dans les transports
les fêtes du Nouvel An chinois risque de
se traduire par une forte hausse des
contaminations et des décès et si
Jean-François Bélanger Radio-Canada
Montréal